bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo on est
ensemble pour 30 minutes d'actualité
européenne à l'heure où les dirigeants
de l'union rencontrent leurs homologues
de l'union africaine à la valette à
malte pour tenter de trouver des
solutions aux dossiers migration nous
allons revenir longuement avec mes
invités sur les racines de cette crise
une crise sans précédent depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale sur le
territoire européen donc faut-il ouvrir
les frontières ou juguler cet afflux
comment quel rôle pour les pays
extérieurs de l'union notamment la
turquie avec moi pour en parler jean
quatremer bonjour vous êtes journaliste
et correspondant du journal libération
ici à bruxelles
merci d'être avec nous jean arthuis vous
êtes député européen membre du groupe
libéral démocrate et président de la
commission des budgets
bienvenue à vous bon enfin emmanuel
maurel vous êtes également député au
sein de cette haute assemblée et vous
êtes député socialiste membre de l'ailé
gauche c'est ça veut dire y'a pas
frondeurs socialiste authentique hockey
sur les socialistes maintenu bon bah
écoute est parfaite
lorik cana l'historique du socialisme
bon avant de discuter plus longuement je
vous propose de revenir un petit peu sur
cette crise c'est un sujet du go barbier
ils seront cent soixante mille réfugiés
relogées dans l'union la décision était
entérinée lors d'un sommet informel en
septembre à bruxelles
trouver une solution pour soulager la
pression migratoire c'est bien la
préoccupation numéro un des pays
européens depuis plusieurs mois depuis
2015 ceux ci doivent faire face au plus
grand exode depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale près d'un million de personnes
auraient atteint l'union européenne
syrie irak afghanistan erythrée les
réfugiés viennent de zones de guerres de
conflits de dictature les conseils
européens et les réunions des ministres
se sont multipliées sans résultat le
sommet de la valette à malte entre
l'union européenne et l'union africaine
est une nouvelle étape organiser le
retour des candidats à l'immigration et
le développement des pays de départ
à l'heure où bruxelles estime que près
de 3 millions de migrants arriveront en
europe dans les deux prochaines années
il faut coûte que coûte
réguler les nouveaux départs vers
l'europe
emmanuel maurel on a réussi à se
partager difficilement 160 mille
réfugiés après plusieurs sommets
européens plusieurs réunions des
ministres de l'intérieur de l'union
européenne
on a on apprend qu'on attend 3 millions
de réfugiés d'ici 2017
l'europe est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
je dirais pas ça comme ça mais il ya
incontestablement on l'a vu avec la
grèce on le voit aujourd'hui avec la
crise des réfugiés une crise du projet
européen et notamment une crise de la
solidarité à quoi on est confronté
concrètement voilà des hommes et des
femmes qui quittent leur pays parce que
ya la guerre parce qu'ils sont
persécutés parce qu'ils sont menacés
dans leur intégrité physique et un
continent comme l'europe qui
s'enorgueillit d'être une terre de
droits de l'homme une terre de droit
d'asile une terre de la démocratie ne
peut pas pinailler alors qu'il s'agit
d'accueillir des gens qui sont menacés
dans leur chair donc là leur apprennent
pardon on pinaille l'europe pinaille à
bas pendant un temps franchement quand
il s'est agi de discuter de comment on
répartissait le retour des égoïsmes
nationaux sur cette question qu'elle
était un peu insupportable je crois que
oui il ya une prise de conscience
incontestablement mais il ya des
opinions publiques qui sont rétives il
ya des gens aussi qui joue avec les
peurs des opinions publiques
la réalité c'est qu'il faudrait
affronter le problème de façon généreuse
humaines et de dire aussi quelque chose
de simple l'europe c'est plus de 500
millions d'habitants il ya une crise en
effet qui risque de nous amener de 3
millions de personnes
et si intelligemment on essayait d
accueillir dignement
je crois que l'europe en est capable et
l'honneur de l'europe
c'est précisément de réussir sa hâte
ancêtres mais vous n'êtes pas d'accord
non mais quand on parle d'europe
c'est un peu facile parce qu'on sait pas
très bien de qui on parle
est ce que ce sont les institutions
européennes aux us comme ce sont les
états en l'occurrence institutions
européennes dans cette affaire ont
plutôt été exemplaire
le premier à prendre la mesure de ce qui
est en train de se jouer c'est jean
claude juncker a compris que ce n'est
pas une crise migratoire laquelle on
l'avait à faire une crise des réfugiés
c'est quand même super différent parce
qu à quel moment on nous l'a présenté au
début comme une crise des tigres à dents
sur mesure mais on a mis un peu de temps
à comprendre
il a fallu la photo du titane pour gérer
ce à partir du mois d'août que
juillet août on a commencé à en prendre
conscience parce qu'auparavant c'était
gérer les flux migratoires habituel et
ce à partir du mois de juin juillet
qu'on voit brutalement un accroissement
du nombre d'arrivées qui n'est il pas
tout simplement parce que les camps
situés en turquie en jordanie au liban
ce vide parce que les gens n'ont plus
d'espoir qu'il ya un règlement rapide de
la question en syrie puis honnêtement
après cinq ans passés dans un camp nou
avec une envie c'est normal et vos
enfants aient un avenir
mais quand vous dites que la commission
européenne a été exemplaire donc vous
pointez dans l'autre sens que c'est les
états qui sont pâles avec ton dérange
elle qui est qu'est ce qui n'est pas
qu'ils refusent de jouer le jeu de la
solidarité
ce sont certains états veut dire
notamment la france parce que la france
n 1 feront la seule à 25% et donc
françois hollande n'est pas très
courageux dans cette affaire et il l'est
angela merkel prendre tous les risques
salut tout et tous les coups vous avez
la hongrie qui n'est pas très généreuse
vous paie les pays d'europe de l'est et
vous avez parmi les plus généreux
l'autriche l'allemagne et la suède
donc c'est un problème étatiques et
pourquoi l'autriche - c'est vrai mais il
parce qu'ils sont divisés entre
conservateurs et socialistes donc au
quand on parle d'europe pour faire très
attention c'est à dire qu'on s'amuse
toujours à mélanger le niveau européen
vraiment communautaire c'est-à-dire
fédéral avec celui des états fédérés
ceux qui ne veulent pas jouer le jeu la
seule vérité ce sont un certain nombre
d'états fédérés qui par ailleurs
bénéficie de la solidarité solidarité
européenne depuis longtemps je parlais
pays d'europe de l'est notamment qui
reçoivent chaque année 4 % de leur pib
en aides structurelles et en politique
agricole commune pac pour cent des
professions d'ailleurs c'était van gogh
ciao bella qui avait dit qu'il n'était
pas dans c'était thomas 2 thomas de
maizière ministre de l'intérieur
allemand qui avait proposé en fait qu'on
coupe ses budgets et ses aides aux pays
de l'est parce qu'il refusait la solide
agents du cayenne gens râlent ils s'en
souviendront un jeu quand on va négocier
les prochains perfidie financière il ya
sans doute quelques pays qui vont alors
quelques difficultés à exploiter de
réclamer de l'argent
jean arthuis vous qui êtes à la tête de
la commission des budgets est ce qu'il
n'ya pas une conditionnalité à mettre en
place
quand on a des pays qui ne rentrent pas
dans le cadre de la solidarité
européenne pendant les pas là mais je
crois qu'il faut surtout qu'on ait une
politique globale
c'est bien que jean claude juncker et
souhaité que l'on relocalise qu'on
répartisse les réfugiés enfin 160 mais
on n'a pas rassemblé 260 mail
il va y avoir sans doute
de cette année un million de
franchissement illégaux des frontières
extérieures de l'europe disproportion
totale et en évoquant la répartition les
quotas on a accrédité l'idée qui valent
à une espèce de fatalité et on se rend
compte que l'europe subit et ça n'est
pas l'europe qui est en cause l'europe a
cru qu'elle avait défini une politique
en matière migratoire
alors qu'elle a laissé l'intégralité des
prérogatives aux états membres
et c'est ça qui fait problème on a 28
pays dans l'union européenne
28 application du droit d'asile dans
certains pays les réfugiés peuvent
travailler instantanément dans d'autres
pays il faut attendre un an ou plus
encore les conditions d'hébergement ne
sont pas les mêmes d'un pays à l'autre
et les réfugiés eux-mêmes finish par
s'interroger pour savoir dans quel pays
il vaut mieux aller plutôt que telle
autre et du courrier en allemagne alors
ils vont plutôt en allemagne c'est ça
que l'on peut être la croissance mais le
même mais le vrai sujet c'est quand même
de s'attaquer aux sources des migrations
s'il ya des guerres s'il ya une
déstabilisation complète au moyen-orient
en syrie en irak
c'est parce que certains européens à un
moment donné sont allés au nom des
printemps arabes sans doute déstabilisé
ce qui pouvait avoir du sens mais les
européens ont été incapables
d'accompagner le mouvement que se
passe-t-il ensuite s'agissant de
l'afrique subsaharienne des courants
migratoires sont très importants elles
sont pas nouveaux mais ils ont été en
partie débridée par le fait qu'il n'y
avait plus de difficultés pour traverser
la libye si donc on était dépouillé de
ses biens mais on pouvait aussi y aller
on peut remercier nicolas sarkozy
d'avoir déstabilisé la libye a coûté
très franchement je trouve qu'on a une
part de responsabilité dans cette crise
cette crise des migrations elle prend sa
source
hors du territoire européen et c'est ça
qui est nouveau et par conséquent si on
veut un minimum d'efficacité et bien
falloir qu au plan diplomatique il ya
une mise en cohérence des positions des
états membres de l'union européenne
si la rue être efficace en termes
diplomatiques
il faut qu'il ya un minimum de capacité
d'intervention militaire et si on veut
calmer le jeu en afrique moi je vois le
problème
des africains sub sahariens il arrive
dans des pays comme la france
ils vont à l'offre à l'ofpra va mettre
un an avant que de savoir s'ils sont
fondés à avoir le statut de réfugié dans
la plupart des cas ils sont déboutés
alors il faut tu appelles ça dure un an
et demi supplémentaires et lorsqu'au
bout de deux ans et demi ils sont
déboutés il n'est plus question de les
rapatrier
parce que les états dans des centres
originaire n'accepte pas qu'il soit
large appétit qui sera en discussion à à
laval à laval et les politiques de
développement une vraie politique de
développement alors à ce moment là il
pourrait y avoir une convention entre
les pays africains et l'union européenne
au terme de laquelle on chiale rage à
développer ces pays d'afrique
subsaharienne mais en contrepartie
lorsqu'un ressortissants de ces pays est
identifié dans l'union européenne
il peut être rapatrié à chantal à une
crise on dit que c'est lui il faut
développer le budget de l'aide au
développement
mais c'est le premier budget qu'on coupe
dès qu'il ya eu dès qu'il ya une crise
justement il comme ça c'est sa trêve
assuré mais comment se fait-il que le
fonds européen de développement n'est
pas intégrée au budget l'union
européenne alors elle sujet c'est
comment il s'y prend surtout c'est
pourquoi est ce que on met en place donc
un sommet à la valette qui se tient
actuellement on va mettre à la table des
négociations
plusieurs chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens plusieurs chefs
d'état et de gouvernement africains et
l'idée c'est quoi c'est des milliards
contre la capacité de réellement
commission allait si mal c'est quand
même un petit peu de cynisme là-dedans
emmanuel quelques mois je la
conditionnalité ne me gêne pas forcément
on l'évoquait au sein de l'union
européenne
là pour le coup ça me gêne c'est un jeu
je trouve que c'est assez cynique de
dire aux africains aux pays du maghreb
l'argent coûte et ont donné de l'argent
si vous aussi vous en gros si vous
juguler la crise migratoire et vous fait
ça dans votre coin mais mais je pense
que c'est pas là je voudrais jamais
vraiment je pense ce n'est pas la
hauteur de ce que doit être l'union
européenne aux gens faut battre moi je
les politiques migratoires on est
d'accord mais vous avez à dire nuire
était exactement moi si vous permettez
je suis là dessus la tête j'avais
d'ailleurs il faut pas se leurrer je
pense qu'il faut pas externaliser il
faut pas conditionner l'aide nécessaire
aux pays aux pays en voie de
développement
vous l'avez dit très justement on passe
notre temps à dire faut être plus plus
solidaires fo plus coopérer et en même
temps tous les états membres mais aussi
de l'union européenne pour le coup
couple aide au développement éric
chose qui ne va pas et on pourrait dire
autre chose par exemple moi je suis en
commission commerce international on
passe notre temps à dire faut aider les
africains et en même temps on prépare
des accords de libre échange qui vont
clairement des structures et leur
industrie leur agriculture leurs
économies donc à un moment il faut une
forme de cohérence
essai de cohérence vous l'avait bien dit
toute façon c'est un problème global et
et l'union européenne a aussi un devoir
de solidarité dans cette affaire parce
qu'elle a des responsabilités pour m
sans précédent dans l'union européenne
et bien sûr la france ou l'europe mourir
serait donc il va être temps donc il va
être temps que c'est une constitution de
cieux et morel parce que les envols
rapport fédéral nous avons au sein d'une
europe qui soient pilotés diriger je
rappelle quand même que c'est françois
mitterrand et helmut kohl qui avait
proposé dans les années 90 82 81 la
création d'un corps de gardes frontières
européens
j'aimerais te dire que ça fait
maintenant 25 ans et à chaque fois que
quand je trouve non mais c'est pas
seulement de l'argent c'est qu'il faut
aussi par exemple que la france elle
accepte qu'une partie de la police de
l'air et des frontières et bien des
dépens de l'europe et celle non n'est
pas question parce que la bce même
pendant quinze ans un bloc et donc
chacun des fonds sa souveraineté parce
que le contrôle des frontières
ça c'est le c'est vraiment la
souveraineté maximale et donc on veut
bien lever les comptes de lever les
contrôles 1 contre des contrôles en
profondeur par exemple schengen rit
toujours abaisser la levée des contrôles
mais c'est le contraire schengen c'est
le c'est l'extension des frontières à
l'intérieur de tous les pays européens
pourquoi la personne la grande bretagne
ne veut pas de schengen pas uniquement
parce qu'elle perd le contrôle de sa
frontière c'est parce qu'elle devait
obliger sa population à voir sans arrêt
sur elle une carte d'identité on vend
quand on rentre en grande bretagne on
n'a plus de carte d'identité
nous en revanche on doit en permanence
pour voir ce justifié
nous on est là sa carte d'identité
exceptionnellement il ya plus de
contrôles schengen c'est pas moyen de
contrôler c'est davantage de contrôler
alors sur l'ensemble des territoires
donc ces baisses demi on a des armes est
séparé oui mais pourquoi parce que les
états ne se font pas confiance
mutuellement et on voit bien que
shenzhen est un espace de déficit de
confiance entre les états pourquoi pas
ce qu'il y'a pas vrais contrôles aux
frontières extérieures derrière alors on
parle aujourd'hui de gardes frontières
mais dites-moi qui va être l'autorité
qui va assurer le commandement qui va
assurer la tutelle
texte voyagiste frontières extérieures
frontex va avoir avec les dotations
complémentaires de la lettre
rectificative dans le budget 2015 on
aura finalement 235 emplois et les états
avec frontex demande aux états 750 mise
à disposition pour l'instant on est à
peu près 300 mises à disposition sur tu
vous pouvez zoomer ne vienne pas parler
des gardes frontières mais là on est
confronté comme un problème budgétaire
tient qu'on a on a un budget de l'union
européenne catégorie qui qui est
tellement à la hauteur des attentes on
est confronté à des crises comme ça qui
arrive brutalement et qui nous
interpelle en tant qu'union européenne
et on est capable de région villaret
fonds ou violents ils viennent des états
membres comme vous suivi alors l arbitre
est obligé de demander aux états membres
de mettre la main à la poche pour le
fonds européen de développement
d'imaginer des trusts fun pour l'afrique
et pour la syrie sur le problème c'est
qu'on est long devant la commission a
demandé 2 milliards 300 millions
et pour l'instant il doit y avoir à peu
près 50 millions 50 millions
d'engagements
donc voilà on compte n'y est pas j'ai
justement c'est une transition toute
trouvée c'est un autre pays à qui on a
promis des milliards contre la gestion
de sa frontière extérieure avec l'europe
c'est la turquie la turquie qui
accueille quasi deux millions et demi de
syriens notamment dans des camps de
réfugiés
c'est flora sauvage qui nous y emmène
reportage
et
des tentes à perte de vue
en face la syrie et ses combats voici le
camp de réfugiés de karkh amish dans la
province de gaziantep en turquie c'est
l'un des 24 camps de réfugiés érigés par
le gouvernement turc
ici les syriens sont entièrement prises
en charge écoles mosquées soins médicaux
tout est prévu
voici la porte par laquelle vous êtes
arrivé comme vous le voyez sur ce plan
le camp est divisé en six quartiers
manipule actuellement le camp atteint sa
capacité maximum six lits à 7212
réfugiés au total pour la moitié
d'hommes et la moitié de femmes érigé en
août 2012
le camp de karkh amish accueille
aujourd'hui plus de 2000 enfants
on a dû construire une école avec des
containers face à l'afflux de réfugiés
on a aussi dû créer une deuxième école
avec huit classes supplémentaires dans
cette école les enfants de 5 à 19 ans
suivent des cours en turc et en arabe
walid était professeur d'anglais en
syrie walton voici m'attendent
il vit désormais sous une tente avec sa
femme et ses quatre fils j'ai un
appartement à alep et une maison à la
campagne
cela fait déjà plus de trois ans que
nous vivons ici dans ce camp au départ
en grand c'est que ça ne durerait pas
mais maintenant ça commence à faire
vraiment longue comme walid beaucoup de
syriens issus de la classe moyenne
supérieure vivent dans les camps de
réfugiés
nous leur donnons 85 livres tueur par
mois par personne équivalents de 27
euros pour qu'ils puissent faire leur
marché s'acheter de la nourriture on
fournit l'électricité les frais médicaux
et tout le reste
la turquie considère les réfugiés comme
des invités c'est donc notre devoir de
nous occuper d'eux tant qu'il le faudra
bonjour bonjour comment ça va hassan et
sa famille sont parmi les premiers à
s'être installés dans le camp de carca
mich
à 57 ans ce maçon a dû fuir à l'aide
alors ça c'est un lay up
il a perdu sa maison et tout ce qu'il
possédait lors d'un bombardement
wade a 9 ans a gardé des séquelles de la
guerre
par ailleurs ma fille est devenue sourde
lors du bombardement de notre maison
désormais hassan survie avec sa femme
ses sept enfants et ses petits enfants
ici en turquie les i ne regrette pas
d'être parti
quarante membres de ma famille ont été
tués dans les bombardements 40 à l'image
d'hassan plus de 2 millions de syriens
ont trouvé refuge en turquie
ils seraient plus de 4 millions à vivre
en exil mais seuls 250 milles syriens
vivent dans les camps de réfugiés
les autres sont disséminés sur le
territoire turc
de son côté l'europe est réticente à
accueillir des réfugiés en nombre et
propose des milliards d'euros à la
turquie pour leur prise en charge
une situation peu acceptable pour les
turcs
irma chiffre donné de l'argent ce n'est
pas la solution
je pense que les autres pays ferait
mieux d'accueillir des réfugiés chez eux
le goût tout s'est vraiment bien d
accueillir mais le problème qui se pose
est économique
ils viennent ici mais la turquie ne peut
pas leur donner permis de travail car
sinon ça serait trop dur pour les turcs
les permis de travail sont délivrés au
compte-gouttes
car les syriens sont considérés comme
des invités et non des réfugiés un
statut qui ne leur permet pas d'exercer
une activité
c'est le cas d'amira qui a trouvé un
travail non déclaré elle a fui la syrie
il y a deux mois
aujourd'hui elle vit seule à gaziantep
avec ses trois enfants alain quand je
suis arrivé ici j'ai profité de
l'hospitalité d'une amie mais ensuite
cet ami a émigré en europe donc je suis
resté un peu et j'ai cherché un travail
et tous les endroits où j'allais les
gens savaient que j'étais seul avec mes
trois enfants
donc ils m'ont donné de la nourriture et
des vêtements
c'est comme ça qu'on a réussi à survivre
jusqu'à ce que je trouve un travail
regardez où j'habite ici cela ne
ressemble à rien je suis un être humain
j'espère trouver un autre logement
bientôt depuis 2011
la turquie a annoncé avoir déjà dépensé
plus de 6 milliards d'euros pour
l'accueil des réfugiés
mais cet accueil semble bien avoir
atteint ses limites
selon ankara le nombre de réfugiés sur
son sol devrait atteindre deux millions
et demi de personnes d'ici à la fin de
l'année 2015
alors la turquie qui dépensent quasi 7
milliards d'euros 2 millions et demi de
turcs deux millions et demi de syriens
en fait sont sur le territoire turc
est ce qu'on peut
décemment demander à la turquie de
prendre en charge complètement cette
crise des réfugiés jean arthuis je crois
qu'il faut aider la turquie
il faut aider le liban il faut aider la
jordanie parce qu on pourrait ajouter
ces deux pays qui accueillent eux au
sein plus d'un million de réfugiés car
si les aider c'est financièrement si
celui-ci ces pays doivent être aidés
impérativement il faut deux choses il
faut aider ces pays pour assurer la
scolarisation des enfants et une vie
digne
il faut aussi contribuer à rétablir la
paix en syrie et au moyen-orient pour
que ces allergies puisse repartir chez
eux
or pour l'instant je ne sais pas où sont
ces crédits on a annoncé 3 3 milliards
oui je ne les ai pas vus dans le budget
en tout cas car il ya des efforts qui
sont faits mais qui ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux encore la fois il
s'agit et ce reportage démontre bien de
réfugiés hier c'est au tour des médecins
des avocats en partie y à peu près de 10
% d'analphabètes qui arrive à quand des
gars en or elle des catégories
professionnelles dont 17,6 ogien vous
êtes avocat vous avez une maison une
résidence secondaire à la campagne en
syrie et vous pensez vous vous retrouvez
pendant trois quatre ans dans un camp de
toile il est normal que les gens aient
envie de venir en europe pour s'offrir
peut-être davantage et dirait d'avenir à
leurs enfants d'offrir davantage d'
avenir à leurs enfants
mais ces gens n'ont pas vocation à
rester chez nous ils nous ont vocation à
rentrer chez eux je vous rappelle que
pendant la guerre de yougoslavie
il ya 900 mille bosniaque qui sont
réfugiés en allemagne et des ils sont
quasiment tous rentrés en bosnie alors
que la bastille c'est quand même pas
donc la centrale nous dire que ont fait
une montagne de pas grand chose
oui on peut les accueillir chez nous
jeudi revenant de rendez vous contre en
france en 2015 il ya eu 8 %
d'augmentation et demande d'asile lui %
pas 80% à 8 100 % imaginez demain qu'on
ait deux millions et demi de réfugiés
syriens chez nous comme la turquie
vous imaginez les forts qu'eux font la
nature donc un peu de respect ces gens
ne fut ne veulent pas venir prendre le
travail des français comme on l'entend
dans le discours je dirais dominant en
france
ils veulent simplement elle vivre en
paix et offrir un avenir à leurs enfants
et à terme de cas situation est calme et
là c'est la question la d2 lab de la
politique étrangère européenne rentrer
dans leur pays et ce en serbie c'est là
qu'est la politique globale alors
emmanuel
elle est ce qu on est en capacité
d'accueillir pourquoi pas deux millions
de syriens vu que nous étions déjà le
mérite de ce reportage c'est de rappeler
quelque chose sur laquelle on assiste
pas assez évidemment ça fait le jeu des
démagogues de tous poils
c'est que la plupart des réfugiés et
viennent pas en europe
ils sont dans la périphérie des pays qui
quittent et aujourd'hui voire même en
parle de la turquie mais on pourrait
parler du liban de la tunisie qui
accueille 1 8 million de libyens
donc c'est des pays quand même qu'ils
font qui font face à des siens lourd
tribut et nous on est en train de
discuter de son intensité dhi vous sur
kelly 800000 en europe et l'europe c'est
500 millions d'avis élan qu'il faut du
nom de ce mois de ce point de vue là il
faut relativiser
je suis totalement d'accord avec
monsieur quatremer sur un point c'est
des réfugiés et quand on regarde dans
l'histoire on va dire l'histoire du 20e
siècle
il ya eu des mouvements massifs de
réfugiés des gens qui ont fui la guerre
ou les persécutions
ils ont été accueillis et la plupart du
temps dans des pays européens et puis
une fois que la situation était
normalisé dans leur pays ils sont
revenus parce qu'on ne tient jamais se
finit évidemment de avec pelé se détend
donc donc et puis par ailleurs je ne
sais pas s'il faut faire la distinction
il y en a qui sont chirurgien d'autres
analphabètes
la réalité c'est que y compris à une
migration économique saas a toujours
existé et peut-être faut-il avoir une
vision un peu dédramatisante par rapport
à ça c'est aujourd'hui je crois 60
millions de migrants dans le monde
ben oui l'europe est un continent riche
pas totalement prospère mais riche en
tout cas elle peut se donner les moyens
accueillir dignement ces gens alors
dernière question est ce que par rapport
à ce que vous disiez à l'instant vous
dire avec l'europe aujourd'hui est une
forme de citadelle assiégée et que on
est un petit peu complètement terrorisée
à l'idée de voir déferler des hordes de
migrants sur notre et quel est le risque
derrière sur quel est le risque en fait
de cette crise vous disiez tout à
l'heure que le risque c'est une
implosion de l'europe
le risque à mon avis est que ceux qui
exercent des responsabilités étatiques
et au plan européen donne l'image d'une
sorte d'impuissance comme s'il y avait
là une espèce de fatalité
or il faut expliquer à nos concitoyens
que nous sommes dans la mondialisation
et que l'urgence
c'est de donner à l'union européenne un
vrai gouvernement de lui permettre
d'avoir une politique extérieure qui
soit audible avec une capacité militaire
qui donne du crédit à la politique
on en est loin un pardon on est loin
très très long je pense que c'est cette
crise des migrations et doit être
lecture au choc d'une prise de
conscience collective pour promouvoir
l'union derrière c'est quoi c'est
l'expression de l'europe
le risque si la patte droite aux europe
en effet attendre et écouter écouter les
populistes et l'écho qu'ils peuvent
avoir ici et là l'urgence c'est d'ouvrir
le débat devant les citoyens et de
refonder le projet le projet européen
car pour l'instant nous avons un
simulacre l'europe est ce que vous êtes
d'accord et manuellement mais moi je
suis d'accord sur le fait que l'europe
peut mourir sur ces questions là mais
comme et peut-être qu'on serait en
désaccord
j'ai été le sidéré par par ce qui s'est
passé avec la grèce parce que mon avis
c'est la même chose la crise du projet
européen en tant que l'espace de
solidarité et l'égalité avec le reste il
s'était solidarisé aussi en son sein ce
n'est pas qu'une question de gouvernance
est aussi une question de conception de
la vie économique et sociale en europe
et aident à passer le vern et à partir
du moment où on est complètement le nez
sur les déficits publics et qu'on
s'occupe pas de la relance de l'activité
et des mémés mais là où vous avez raison
de toute façon c'est que ça doit être un
électrochoc et ça doit être le sursaut
c'est possible parce que vous parlez les
risques les risques c'est d'abord la
fracture au sein des états membres
wen a vu le groupe de vice grave mais il
pourrait y avoir une fracture est
évident c'est aussi le prix politique
s'il n'y a pas d une façon de
sensibiliser nos concitoyens au problème
évidemment il ya des europhobes qui vont
s'emparer de sa déclination de menacer
le projet européen inter jean quatremer
rapidement le parallèle entre la grèce
et la syrie personnellement je ne le
partage pas parce que je pense pas que
les européens a été faire en syrie ce
que bachar al assad
mais frédéric asseman je fais pas voilà
donc la solidarité a fonctionné en
l'occurrence
alors prêté 320 milliards d'euros donc
sa vérité a fonctionné sur danger
d'extinction est un vrai danger
d'explosion de l'europe
ce que dit la chancelière elle-même ce
qui se passe actuellement en europe
c'est ainsi que naissent les conflits là
aujourd'hui l'écho isme nationale qui
consiste à se renvoyer les réfugiés et
les migrants les gens chez les autres
meilleurs après la chute du mur avaient
un meilleur moyen pour que demain on
règle la question d'une façon militaire
ça arrivera si on continue comme ça donc
il faut aujourd'hui un sursaut qui me
pète que fédéralisme et ça ça l'est
peut-être que ça va peut-être convaincre
justement les frondeurs du parti ce sera
peut-être le rejoint ce sera l'objet
messieurs d'un autre débat merci à vous
de nous avoir éclairé sur cette question
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
chao merci à tous
ouais